What's the fuel consumption of a car? Say,
on the highway moving at highway speeds? We
can look it up, but can we understand those
numbers? Can we predict them from our knowledge
of science and engineering? That's what we're
gonna do in this video.
This video is part of the problem solving
video series.
Problem-solving skills, in combination with
an understanding of the natural and human-made
world, are critical to the design and optimization
of systems and processes.
Hi, my name is Sanjoy Mahajan, and I'm a professor
of Applied Science and Engineering at Olin
College. And I excel at streetfighting mathematics.
Before watching this video, you should be
familiar with free body diagrams and dimensional
analysis.
After watching this video, you will be able
to: Model drag to predict terminal velocities;
and Determine the fuel efficiency of a car.
Fuel is consumed in fighting drag, on the
highway at least. What's the force of drag
on a car? That's fluid mechanics. We could
try the hard way—solving the Navier-Stokes,
the equations of fluid mechanics.
Now after 10 years of learning mathematics,
you'll discover this is a really hard problem.
You can only solve it analytically in certain
special cases like a sphere moving at really
slow speeds and a car is not one of those
special cases; certainly not a car moving
at any reasonable speed. So we need another
way.
By applying approximations artfully, we're
gonna find the drag force and the fuel consumption
of a car with a simple experiment and some
scientific and engineering reasoning.
First, we need to model drag. To do this,
we're gonna figure out how the drag force
depends on the quantities that control it.
Drag force F depends on the density of the
air, to some power which we don't know yet,
times the speed of the car moving through
the air, to some power we don't know yet.
It depends on how big the car is, which we'll
represent by the area; traditionally, the
cross- sectional area, to some power. And
it also can depend on the viscosity here,
the kinematic viscosity of the air to some
power. And what those powers are, we don't
yet know. To figure them out, let's do an
experiment.
For the experiment, we make two cones. First,
by making a large circle and cutting out a
quarter of it. The large circle has a radius
of seven centimeters. And the small three-quarter
circle has half the radius. Cut them out and
then tape this edge to that edge and this
edge to that edge in order to make the 2 cones.
Next we're gonna race them, the big cone vs.
the small cone. But first, make a prediction.
The question is: what is the ratio of fall
speeds of the big cone and the small cone
approximately? Is the big cone roughly twice
as fast, is the small cone twice as fast,
or do they fall at roughly the same speed?
Pause the video and make your best guess.
You may want to try the experiment yourself.
The experimental result is that they both
fall at roughly the same speed. Now what does
that mean for the exponents in the drag force?
To decide, use a free body diagram. Here is
a free body diagram of a cone as it falls.
What are the forces on the cone? Pause and
fill in the diagram.
There is drag and gravity. Because the cones
are falling at their terminal speed, in other
words at the constant velocity that they reach
pretty quickly, the drag must equal the force
due to gravity.
So the drag force can easily be measured just
by sticking the cones on a scale. We don't
actually have to stick the cones on a scale
because we know what their relative weights
are and that's what we're gonna use to figure
out one of the exponents.
Knowing that the drag equals the force due
to gravity, let's compare the drag forces,
which are the factors on the right side, of
the small and large cones. The large cone
was made out of a paper circle with twice
the radius so it has four times the area,
four times the mass, and four times the force
due to gravity. Therefore, four times the
drag force.
Now let's look at the causes one by one. This
density here is the density of the air and
both cones feel the same air so there's no
difference here, so that's times one no matter
the exponent. Now, what about the speed? The
speeds were the same; that was the result
of our experiment, so no matter what the exponent
here, the speed contributes to the effect
by a factor of one; in other words, nothing.
Now the area. This is traditionally the cross-sectional
area. The big cone has four times the cross-sectional
area of the small cone so this area factor
is times four and raised to the unknown exponent.
And here, the kinematic viscosity, that's
the kinematic viscosity of air and both cones
feel the same kinematic viscosity. Therefore,
that contributes a factor of one just like
the density does.
So now we know what the question mark here
has to be. The question mark here must be
one so that this four to the question mark
is equal to this four. And so does this one.
Now that we have found one exponent, we can
find the remaining three using dimensional
analysis.
We make sure that the exponents chosen on
the right side produce dimensions of force,
which are the dimensions on the left side.
A force has dimensions of mass, length per
time squared, that's mass times acceleration.
Density has dimensions of mass per length
cubed, raised to this unknown exponent. Velocity
has dimensions of length per time, raised
to this unknown exponent. Area has dimensions
of length squared, raised to the power 1,
we've already figured that out. And kinematic
viscosity; now, that's the regular viscosity
divided by the density. It has dimensions
of length squared per time raised to this
unknown exponent
Now let's solve for these unknown exponents
one at a time. Looking first at the mass,
there is mass here and mass here on the left
side, but there is no other mass. So the only
way to get the mass to work out is to make
this exponent one.
Now, what do we have left? We have to make
sure the lengths and times work out and we
have two unknowns, this exponent and this
exponent.
Let's see how many more lengths we need, given
what we already have. We have mass worked
out, we have two lengths here over three lengths
so we have mass per length. So we have length
to the minus one so far.
And what about time? Well, we have no times
yet except in these question marks so we need
to get two more times on the bottom two more
lengths on the top. So we need to multiply
by length squared over time squared, and the
only way to do that is to make this exponent
a two... and this exponent here a zero.
You can pause the video and go ahead and try
other combinations of exponents. You'll find
that none of them will get both length and
time correct.
So now we have all the exponents, we can actually
enter that into our force formula. Drag force
is proportional to density to the first power,
speed squared, area to the first power we
got from our home experiment and viscosity
here to the zeroth power.
Now let's test our formula with a second demonstration
and see if it predicts this new situation.
We're gonna race four small cones stacked
on top of each other. One, two, three, four.
So we stack them to make one small cone that
is four times the mass of the other small
cone. Next we're going to race them.
But first, what's the drag force ratio between
the small cone and 4 small cones stacked together.
Pause the video and use the formula to make
a prediction.
The four cones weigh four times as much as
one cone so that's times four on the left
side. What about the right side? Again, both
contestants feel the same air density. The
velocity ratio, that's what we're trying to
figure out, and let's see what all the other
pieces are. The area; well here in this case,
the stack of four has the same cross- sectional
area as the one cone so that's just one. And
the viscosity doesn't matter. So, this factor
of four on the left side has to be produced
by the v squared; in other words, the v goes
up by a factor of two so that when it's squared,
you get a factor of four. That means the correct
answer should be two to one.
Now, let's test our prediction with a demonstration
to check whether nature behaves as we predict.
It looks like our prediction was correct!
Now we feel pretty confident that we can use
this formula to try to figure out the fuel
consumption of a car.
Let's clean up our formula here just a bit
and erase the viscosity since it comes in
with a zero exponent so it doesn't matter.
And this is our drag formula, which we're
gonna use to estimate the fuel consumption
of a car on the highway.
Fuel efficiency is measured as the distance
that that the car travels on one gallon or
liter of gasoline.
So it depends on how much energy you can get
out of a gallon of gasoline divided by the
drag force, which is the formula we've just
found.
So let's put in some numbers. What's the energy
from a gallon of gasoline? A gallon is roughly
4 liters. And gasoline is roughly like water
so, there are 1,000g/liter.
How much energy do you get out of each gram
of gasoline? Gasoline is like fat and from
the side of a butter packet, you can read
that 100 kilocalories, 10 to the 2 kilocalories
come from 11 grams of butter.
But now we want to convert kilocalories to
some reasonable metric unit. So that's four
joules/calorie or four kilojoules per kilocalorie.
And that all divided by the drag force so
let's put in those terms one by one.
First the density here, one kilogram per meter
cubed is the density of air roughly. Now v
for highway speeds. Say 100 kilometers an
hour, 65 miles an hour. That's roughly 30
meters per second. Don't forget to square
it. And then the area of a car. Well, it's
about... two meters wide by 1.5 meters high.
Now we have to work all the numbers, but before
you do that, pause the video to check that
the dimensions all cancel appropriately.
You should have found that the result has
units of meters, which is good! But how many?
A quick numerical approximation will tell
you that you get 50 kilometers, which is 30
miles roughly. The fuel efficiency of a car
on the highway is about 30 miles per gallon;
or 50 kilometers per gallon. In typical European
Union units, that's eight liters per hundred
kilometers.To Review With our approximation
methods, we've come to pretty reasonable numbers
for the fuel efficiency of a car, without
having to solve any of the complicated equations
of fluid mechanics. Instead, we used one simple
home experiment, dropping the cones, and the
powerful principle of dimensional analysis.
From that, we were able to find all the exponents
here, in the relationship between drag and
density, speed, and cross-sectional area.
So the moral of this is that there is an art
to approximations, and reasoning tools such
as dimensional analysis, they give you an
understanding of how systems behave without
having to solve every single last bit of the
detailed mathematics. This understanding allows
us to redesign the world.